just woken up Doo and
chibi they woke up as
well and this is how we start our day
here
look still dark it is
5:30 and I got to get
ready all right so I got my night gown
on there go CHP mils come on
these lights are so strong the first
thing I do is I need to give too and
chibi some milk and milk you said
too
okay I got to make some coffee for me
and
aido now while I'm making the coffee I
got to take Togo and chibi to go and do
their thing outside peepi
okay go go go
go I say nice to
go there you go
chibi launch control let's go let's go
come on S let's move let's
[Music]
move
all
right some
coffee go so this is how we start the
day usually me and Nik very quick
disconnecting with a cup of coffee
che che and with Togo and chibi of
course and then uh we usually read the
Bible together 2 Peter 1
verse3 this is beautiful his divine
power has granted to us all things that
that pertain to life and
godliness thank you Father for giving us
life thank you for giving us everything
that we have especially the things that
we take for granted that we don't
appreciate father I ask that
you be with us today and help us to
smell the flowers and see the beauty in
the life that you have created but also
while we do that please help us with
everything we need to do today with the
two YouTube channels the Ministries
and the filming this morning and all the
meetings father we just want to move in
your will so please help us in Jesus
name we pray amen
amen so I've Got My Gym close on because
I'm going to go to the gym after the
morning meeting and before the morning
meeting with the dlm team there's a few
things I need to take care of a few
priorities and so it's just much easier
I try to go to the gym every single day
the time that I do that just uh that's a
little bit different depending on what I
need to do that
[Music]
day now I also do a quick trim I just
trim the hair and cut it all off here on
my cheeks here on the sides and then
also here on my
neck this is the best water bottle I
carry it with me throughout the day it
keeps the water nice and cool the whole
day and it also just helps me to remind
myself hey you need to drink
[Music]
water so this is what I do in the
morning I have breakfast just oats with
some nuts mix nuts and then uh of course
the blueberries or any other kind of
fruit sometimes I love bananas as well
sometimes I even throw in there some
peanut
butter so this is it and then while I
eat oh and with white protein of course
if I work out and then while I eat I
just go through the things that I need
to do in the day I schedule my priority
list it's always things that you got to
sacrifice certain things that just are
more important than others and so for me
just running DM Christian Lifestyle the
men's lifestyle a new company that we're
going to call Ro
entertainment disciple well I can't
speak too much there's a few other
things as well and so there's a lot of
things um that sometimes require my
attention before other people can
continue their work like the editors I
need to tell them what to do what to use
and also sometimes I need to trim the
footage which I will probably do in the
next few hours um maybe two hours before
the meeting
starts thank you Father for the food and
thank you for this amazing day this is a
day that you have made I will rejoice
and I will be glad in it thank you so
much and help me with the the list and
everything I have to do in Jesus name
amen it's so important to start your day
the right
way breakfast is done too and chibi are
always close by there they are oh man
the best dogs ever well for me they're
not dogs they're like fair kids for me
and
Nikita for some of you who do not know
theid and I might not have any kids and
um if that's God's will it's his will I
will be content with that but we are
praying for kids so we'll see what
happens now I just want to quickly
explain to you something we're actually
planning on moving to the USA some of
you already know that but in the
meantime we kind of let go of our house
and everything and now we live in this
furnished place somehow we got this
beautiful Loc location and at a fraction
of the cost there's a few things like we
have to move out in December months and
certain months for the owners we can't
use the garage there's a there's a few
other things few things that was wrong
with the plumbing and it's just a lot
but God helped us with this place so
that we can come here and film videos
you can just hear all the bird sounds
here and we're just working so hard that
we don't get a lot of time to to really
appreciate the place oh Togo and chibi
want to want to get out oh too chibi
okay come on guys all right so I'm
drinking in every moment that we stay
here because the previous place we
stayed at was very small it's all we
could have afforded and um that was more
inside the city and there was just a lot
of noise and my goodness it's not that
I'm I'm uh complaining I'm just very
very happy and so so thankful to God for
this place that we can record film
videos when it's quiet you do hear a
little bit of cars every now and then
you see see them driving
there but that's easy to take out with
Adobe addition if it's the same noise
right and so I just wanted to share this
with you guys don't think we're rich at
all because we're not but we got this
place only through God and so we're only
going to stay here for a little bit
until we have to move to America and
we're in the queue we're just waiting
for the embassy here in South Africa or
the consulate uh to give us a date and
then uh we can go to the appointment and
then we can get our visas and then we
can move to
America so this is it guys this is my
little Studio here where I sit and work
most of the days if I'm not out filming
or doing something outside and then
sometimes Togo is here wants me to pick
him up there we
go okay okay okay I do have a little bit
of time before the meeting starts 2
hours so there's a lot I can do in two
hours I need to trim some footage I need
to check some emails I need to do a lot
of basic stuff and just get ready for
that meeting so let's get to
itoo
wow that is beautiful it's going to be a
beautiful day Daniel here with DM men's
lifestyle and today we're going hunting
in South
[Music]
Africa
all right so this video is exporting and
now I need to go and take my
supplements oh good morning Nikita good
morning Nikita is awake and he's
working good
morning already at work yep of course
what's the time there I have a lot to do
uh 7:56 in the morning nice I like it I
like it give me a fish
bomb so these are my supplements Sunday
to Saturday now one day I might tell you
and show you everything that I use but
um I'm not sick or anything this is just
to keep me running and it's very good
I'll add it in a video description for
you one of the most important thing here
is the Vitamin D it just helps you so
much just uh having a strong body to
fight any kind of disease getting cold
or uh anything
else all right so we got the pills and
our our guard dog is barking here for
something what's it
huh and chibi is here as well what is it
what is it
okay relax relax relax buddy relax
there's nothing there's nothing what is
it is it is it the the
OPA yeah done so sometimes there's
monkeys here and he really doesn't like
the monkeys when I when he hears the
sounds come on let's go come on let's
[Music]
go so that was just K now and that's
jock they just woke up they're visiting
us for a little bit is doing all the
social media steing her pajamas and then
that's Jo of course you know him already
the video editor and you know col she
doesn't like videos at all so you'll see
her jumping out of the shots every now
and then which is strange because last
night she accidentally actually did a
whole telegram live video accidentally
by
herself all right so Nikita asked me to
come so we can talk about a few things
here yep and is working with yeah he's
always working with there chibi so
there's a few things we need to discuss
see you guys
later right I got 15 minutes before we
have the tea meeting and that means I've
got some time to make some
[Music]
coffee all right now this is the coolest
thing to keep your coffee warm because
cold coffee is not good unless it's iced
coffee on a very hot day but this is
going to keep it warm for 3 four 5 hours
maybe
even good morning good morning okay
let's
pray father thank you so much for
another day thank you that we can just
dig into your word please speak to us
amen amen there's another verse that
says but we should take all all our
thoughts captive bring it under the
Obedience of Christ that's all I want to
read today after that he talks about the
coming of the Lord and it's interesting
but I just want to focus on this part
where it's about just living a life
that's pleasing to God and just
reminding us to control our bodies
meaning our flesh as well you know the
desires everything that we want to do
bring it under the lordship of Jesus he
is now Lord right we accept him as Lord
and Savior not just you get your ticket
into into heaven but you want to be the
Lord of your own life Jesus is the Lord
of your own life he sits on your throne
you follow him in this newness of Life
full stop is there anything that you
guys want to share I think something
that stands out for me is that it's your
own
responsibility to uh build that
relationship with God no one can live
for you or pray for you or read Bible
for you an important part for me is also
that verse 11 to mind your own Affairs
and to work work with your hands as we
instructed you cuz they always stick
their noses in somewhere where they
don't belong stop looking into other
people's lives and you know focus on on
your life and your growth and with the
Lord and your relationship and and to
work with your hands so that part kind
of goes into the next way that you can
understand it of for example people
always wanting to have what others have
but then they're not willing to put in
the work themselves the hard work the
hard labor with their own hands and do
the Deeds you know to to get somewhere
in life if we want our faith to be as
high and as strong as other people why
aren't we doing that effort and and
putting in that hard work I was also
going to say also like with that part
where you know it's so easy to pinpoint
in other people's lives there's like um
Al like always wanting to pinpoint in
other people's lives like all the little
SP in their eyes but it's like you need
to First Take out the log in your own
eye thank you for that for Fus on your
own life the Bible does talk about busy
bodies and
gossips you guys are right anyone else
who want to share anything um yeah so
it's just that part also that Nikita and
Janine just spoke about I think we need
to talk less and listen more sometimes
and because I think you need to be
informed about the things that's going
on around you aspire to live quietly
understand so don't be the reason
somebody else stumbles and don't be the
reason somebody else uh um gossips uh
because sometimes a word or a gesture or
iral can perhaps be more than words um
and and our actions also our actions can
speak louder than words as as the as
that proverb says I always say I'm a
work in progress understand so I'm under
construction so every day I take it on
God's grace and as you read and and
learn and study God's word I think it's
it becomes easier but yeah there's also
that self um respons responsibility
almost uh in yourself understand to
abstain from these things and the key in
it is that you can't do it on your own
through our own efforts we will not be
able to abstain of from anything of this
if we don't allow God to take the wheel
in a sense and and guide us in
everything that we do thank you Donnie
that's good anyone else want to say how
fitting it is to the newsletter that you
literally sa us this week I've been
reading it it was a good message because
are you selfish or selfless and the one
part that stood out to me was Galatians
2:20 where it says Jaden Jaden I have
been crucified with Christ it is no
longer I who live but Christ who lives
in me that's for me that stands up this
morning is um verse S for God has not
called us for impurity but in Holiness
therefore whoever disregards this this
disregards not man but God gives his
holy spirit to you and
it's it's what Roman is getting ready I
see him I see him here we go here we
go the important part for me is that uh
the sanctification is the will of God
because uh sometime we we miss this part
because uh some teachings in Nepal in
our country some people are
preaching like we all are justified by
God and uh now we are no more sinner
longer so we don't need to repent or we
don't need to live a holy life something
like that uh but the true thing is we
all are in a long journey of
sanctification uh we grow day by day in
Christ and he changed our hearts and he
want us to move on from one glory to
another Glory this is the very important
part for me that the sanctification is
the will of God and we need to live our
life holy as he is
Holy that's it so thank you so much
Daniel for saying the
word that's good and so true it's so
clear in the word like you say Roman and
so when people don't preach it it's just
the devil is at work yeah go on sin
don't worry about it go on it's also um
verse seven and 8 that stood out for me
today K did you want to add something
maybe you've talked too much yesterday
when you did The Accidental live video
on on Telegram so maybe you've talked a
lot already um but in case you want to
talk a little bit more then then go go
ahead I just have one thing to
add um it it goes hand in hand with what
Roman and Damon and Leon also talked
about about how they are showing
brotherly love for one another and it
says for that indeed is what you are
doing to all the brothers throughout
Macedonia but we urge you Brothers to do
so more and more so I think it's
important to remember to not just get
comfortable um with the position that
you are at or in the the progress that
you have made but to continue to strive
to do better and to please God more and
more and to walk in his will more and
more and to love other people more and
more to spend more time with God to get
to know him better climb this mountain
until until the day you right so I agree
and I I agree with everything you guys
have said but I got to ask you
this it's easy to talk about these
things to identify these truths but what
are you actually doing about
it do you have a structure that you're
working on do you have a book you're
working through do you have a Bible
study that you say you're going to have
a a habit to change yourself and to to
grow holy what are you doing are you
making a list of all the things that you
know you should change in your life are
you makeing it a priority so what I'm
saying is just
thinking about okay this is my goal I I
want to be live holy I want to do this
but just keeping it there and doing
nothing about it means you will never
reach it because you're still staying
stuck you can see the truth you
understand it but you're not moving
you're not doing anything about it so
you need to create a structure you need
to change your habit you need to do a
lot of things to actually start moving
like Jo says don't stand still you need
to start taking that first step and
there a saying that also says a thousand
miles starts with a single step
you will say those single steps in a lot
of different things in your life there's
different seasons different times and
whatever God wants you to do of course
we already know he wants you to live
holy but how do you do that what does he
want you to do with editing family who
you marry there's a lot of things in
your life right but in all those things
you need to step that first step with
the holy spirit that helps you to go the
right direction because you're not alone
anymore as Janine said my life is Christ
you died you don't live anymore and so
we need to move with him would you close
our eyes in prayer yeah sure Close Our
Eyes uh Lord just thank you for this um
great message Lord just uh the
reminder again that this road of
sanctification that we're on Lord is not
a it's not a it's not a road that has an
ending it but it's uh it's a it's it's a
path and in a rad that we will need to
walk until the day that we die as J also
said help us to take it to heart help us
to implement these things that we
discuss in our own lives as well so that
in order of us doing so that we can be
an example for those around us what it
means to live holy amen amen amen thank
you so much let's start with the standup
so there's a few things we need to talk
about but before we talk about the
editors and after that the marketing and
social media and everything else two
hours later okay cool all right okay
bye wow it's after
12:00 sometimes that's how it goes uh
it's after 12:00 already I'm going to
head to the gym because uh I made it a
point to really take care of my body and
so it's something that I need to do and
Jo and Nikita is going to join me yes
are you ready I'm ready for the gym
Nikita you ready for the
gym call now you ready let's go
phone you need your
phone my phone okay go get your phone
ke I'm going to drive away for
K can't the door is
[Music]
open Daniel K is taking too long that's
it if you snooze he lose sorry K
goodbye where is
she you need to be
fast watch out watch out watch
out and you got my water thank
you good job
G let's go these people are still busy
building my
goodness this is where all the noise
come from the noise comes from Daniel
yeah when you want to film videos and
then when you're ready everything is set
camera is set you make time for it and
then when you just say hey welcome to DM
men's lifestyle you
hear the problems of content
creators anyway let's do this let's get
to the
gym all right here we are let's get
Kraken Kraken
[Music]
one
nothing woo that was a workout so
Nikita and them they're not done yet so
I came to the car to quickly see if I
can quickly reply a few people voice
messages and normal messages and just do
a bit
of admin because um it's the first time
that I looked at my phone today and it's
just going so busy every day that you
have to take these moments and use every
minute that you have effectively so I'm
going to sit here while I wait for them
it's too noisy inside and it's it's
quicker for me to just to answer with a
voice message than just to set and type
so that's what I'm going to do now and
then uh I might even ask Nikita or one
of them to drive us back home it's
around 20 minutes so that I can still do
some
work good to hear from you it's been a
while apologies that I'm only replying
to you
now you guys done who's going to drive
will you drive or you thanks Jo Nikita
how you
feeling they look
dead that is what the air bike does to
you now I sounded like a proper South
African Air Bike real love
relationship I'm dying don't want to get
sweat on your seats oh thank
you
okay
said oh so you see we we we just arrived
at the car and it's already admin
already like houses and stuff and
looking at different rents and all these
kind of stuff it doesn't stop yeah work
work work work work no excuses only
results I like it I like it Nikita more
passion more passion more energy more
energy more footwork more
footwork more ding work more ding work
yeah so we're going to work a little bit
in this 20 minutes and I'll see you back
at the house bye
bye and we are home I got to hit the
shower I only have 30 minutes before the
next meeting so when it comes to
grooming and everything else I usually
just use geology there's a lot of other
products as well I'll add everything for
you in the video description so this
takes care of my hair this takes care of
my face and my body geology is special
I'm just going to get a towel and stuff
geology is special because it's
specifically
uniquely designed formulated for your
unique Skin So for me I have I've got
dark circles I've got the pores here on
my nose which I don't like sometimes
pimples and so this takes care of
everything and also I'm getting older
I'm 37 now so it helps me with uh
wrinkles and stuff as well the cool
thing about it is that it's a
subscription so they just send it to you
every
month okay to okay too you want to take
a shower with
Dad oh one of the best things in life is
a hot shower
all right so for my hair I just take
some sea salt spray and because I'm in a
rush I'm just going to blow dry it very
quickly and it helps me to style my hair
just a lot
quicker all right you guys can see it's
a lot better already just to style this
so what I usually do is I just use a
little bit of a American Crew and um I
just put in a little
bit just to set
[Music]
it and then if I really want to I add a
little bit of hairspray at the end but
um yeah that should be fine then just a
little bit of
hairspray and that's
done cool ready for the meeting and then
the only other thing is my beard you
know the beard can be rough and tough
and all over the place so what I
sometimes do is I use this this is from
beard brand
and then I just use a little bit and
it's basically just the same thing just
put it in there now you can go crazy you
can do different beer Styles like even
this guy he can do that and just roll it
up go old nobleman likee or you just
bring it down and you go more like
Viking style anyway I just like to make
it normal
neat and um I think that's fine
so I'm on my way to the meeting and I
forgot I didn't actually eat anything
else except breakfast this morning and
it's already almost 3:00 so I'm going to
have whe protein muscle tech nitr
tech usually I like to add bananas and
everything else but today I just don't
have time so I'm just going to grab a
handful of nuts and here we go now I'm
going to take this eat this drink this
while we
move
okay so the light is a little bit
intense here so sorry about the video
quality I'm using the GoPro here and I'm
using the camera here to have the
interviews now I just have a few minutes
and I'm going to check in with Don and
col marketing manager social media
manager because we're looking at getting
someone else that will help us with
social media and we have an appointment
with them at 3 so we're just going to
talk about a few things then we're going
to have that meeting and uh I'll show
show you just uh some glimpses of it
here and
there oh just so you know I need to put
on this light because otherwise it's too
dark here so this is going to be intense
for you to see
but this is the life of content
creators yeah it's intense even for me
sometimes gets hot in here but it is
what it
is so we use
Discord for all the
meetings hello hello hello
what yeah so just just just so you guys
know um we are Africans right me K and
Don and so we're going to continue this
meeting in all right so
is like like elf
[Music]
um
yeah all right okay so the countown
is okay right okay guys so now got to
jump over to the next
meeting with the guy that we might use
for social media we'll see if it is a
good fit or not so he is also from South
Africa so we'll probably speak
Africans Adrian hello hello
hello I would like to start with a
prayer if that's okay with
you
amen cool
excited just all right right bye all
cheers all right guys it's another
meeting done so it's going to work we
have someone that's going to help us
with social media he's going to start
next week so then went pretty well now
there are two meetings left for
today um I'm not going to bore you with
too much information but we're starting
something else a different company
called Rock entertainment and we're
working with a lot of people so I have
two meetings with three people after
that with all the uh Sherpas team
leaders managers as we can call it and
um that's going to be a little bit
longer and then only we're done with the
tea meetings I'm just going to make some
coffee but I just want to hear how jock
is doing with the editors jock how's
everything going uh yeah it's going good
multitasking a bit really are you busy
cutting up the the recording you did
this morning that you guys probably
already saw and uh also on a call with
Sandra one of our video editors uh all
right I'm going to leave you alone then
okay so I have a window of time quickly
to make some coffee and then I'm also
going to just take Togo and chibi to do
their thing outside and then uh just
take a moment to take in the view you
know sometimes you get so busy with the
rat race that you forget to enjoy life
and just stop a little bit and smell the
flowers so let me take to chibi first to
let's go come come come come come
come oh say beepy
[Music]
peepe there go chibi let's go come
on
you know guys we have awesome merch of a
lot of interesting designs like this one
truth that you can get on our store all
the details is in the video description
down below I think we have definitely
over 10 let's say 15 around there a lot
of interesting designs check it
out I'm wearing one of them as well
Integrity so
good ooh I just realized that too and
chibi usually I give them a a snack you
know every now and then but uh they keep
looking at me and I just realized I did
not give them snacks yet huh Togo chibi
I think it's time okay okay snacky okay
okay okay we are there huh all right
let's do this FY
by that's one for you go set freaky
by well done well done don't eat
this they have to wait until I tell them
it is
time okay well done it's time to get
back to work Nikita is busy here Nikita
is busy here with another meeting
already yeah it's to the art meeting hey
guys I'll blur this if you don't want me
to show
[Laughter]
this he's busy filming like a vlog video
of a day doing her thing as well his
work and so I have around 15 minutes so
I'm going to do a few emails and then
I'm going to jump into the next meeting
this is it guys this is basically the
life of a Preacher vlogger content
creator and um just a guy who's who's
running two you YouTube channels and all
that that includes and then also the the
new company Rock entertainment which is
man I'm burning to tell you guys about
this but you just have to watch
because it's going to be
[Music]
big oh it's getting hot this so strange
downstairs it's cold and up here it's
hot in this
room
according to your will
amen amen thank you thank you okay
so here we go another meeting hello
hello
hello I like it I also want to pray that
you be with us in this meeting Lord so
um we can keep
progressing great it in your name
amen amen I don't know I I think it's a
good reminder actually for all of us
just to just hand or just extend those
invitations again to the teams thanks
everyonee all right guys that's it the
last meeting for the day and it's
getting dark outside and my work is only
starting I'm done with all the meetings
and the admin and everything I had to do
but now it's time to do my own work
prepare sermons and um also trim this
video that I've been filming the whole
day but first I need to take Togo and
chibi to go and do their thing outside
peepe peee peepe let's go let's
go it is almost 7:00 here at night M man
I just love this
view that was quick
too let's go let's
go Dan H you ain't not seeing anything
what what what's up what's going on
there you're not seeing anything it is
not Assassin's Creed Mirage on my screen
oh man devil games Nikita it's off time
well I need to test it to see the game
functionality and like the the user
interface designed to like kind of plan
and know if it works good why do you
need to do that for our future projects
they don't know anything I'm I'm not
going to say too much yeah they don't
know anything about our projects I know
that's why I'm just saying future
projects are you guys going to play
games as well I just need birth now oh
you tired it's been a long day working
with all the editors yeah I know it's
been a busy day me too
but we still have a few hours of work
left no we got a few hours of gam
playing Left maybe you I like that
t-shirt Nikita what is that thank you so
much win and out play it out nice our
new merch huh yes one of the new ones be
sure to get it isn't she
cute this is my wife everybody okay I
had my quotes of English speaking bye
guys love you too and chibi food Togo
and chibi got their food so I think I'm
going to make something very very quick
because I'm hungry and then uh I'm going
to continue to
work just going to add some
mushrooms some
onions then some
jalapenos some belong ooh look at
that and this is for too and chibi too
chibi sit
turn nice there you
go now just in case if you don't know
what bong is that's like big jerky but
just so much better some salt
eggs going
in nikito are you
hungry
yeah not for this your own food maybe
yeah okay I think I'm going to finish my
healthy salad
M okay now this is one of my favorite
smoked chili flakes this is so good oh
nice Nikita is it okay if I pray for us
quick yes okay since you're going to eat
your salad and I'm going to eat it
wellow this delicious food yes it is
father thank you so much for this day
thank you for all the meetings thank you
for all your blessings and
um I just appreciate you so much and I
know Nikita does too thank you for our
marriage thank you for just always being
there for
us in Jesus name amen
[Music]
amen m
[Applause]
all right guys so it is slowly getting
late but I still got a lot of work to
do got to trim all the footage that I've
taken today got to plan for the next day
and um also got to prepare a sermon that
I'm going to do on man's lifestyle and
that's going to come a little bit later
and the video is going to be called how
to be a great
father
so I also have to respond to a few
people on Ro
entertainment do a few things there and
um I'm going to work until I get too
tired and uh then I'm going to go and
I'm going to chill a little bit with
Nikita with the dogs and then sleep wake
up
repeat let me get to some
[Music]
work
what's it too what's it chibi if too and
chibi want to go to bed they let me know
so I've been working a little bit late
and uh it is time to go spend some time
with them and also with Nikita what's it
Doo what's a
TB how we going to go let's
go let's go let's go
oh going chibi is it time for bed
M
chibi a look at you
too all right so my night routine is
just to use geology for my face to wash
it and uh if I don't have geology well
let me just show you first too so this
is geology I use this to wash my face
put on the cream and then uh if I don't
have that I would sometimes just use
Clinique just brush my teeth so that's
basically basically it guys I'm not
going to share with you everything we do
now because now it's me and Nikita just
having some time together maybe even
read Bible together and uh maybe even
watch something together and um that's
it that's it for the day and then
tomorrow is just repeat so that's my
daily life sometimes I just have to film
sometimes I do collab sometimes radio
interviews because of my new book that
just came out there's a lot of things
that I uh that I do but I can't share
everything with you right now especially
Rach entertainment and uh you got to
keep your eyes out for that because
there's a few more interesting things is
going to come next is going to be a
men's trip with Donnie and with jock a
leadership kind of trip and we're just
going to pray together spend some time
together we're going to do some fishing
we're going to do some hunting we're
going to do some men's stuff so I'll see
you in that video bye